acciones de derechos humanos bolivia
arremete contra el gobierno del
expresidente argentino mauricio macri el
canciller del país andino rogelio mayta
sacudió este jueves el tablero político
regional al revelar pruebas que salpican
al anterior gobierno argentino y lo
involucran en los hechos de violencia
que en 2019 terminaron con la salida de
evo morales- del poder pero resaltamos
que la argentina presidida por mauricio
macri le dio a las fuerzas militares que
reprimieron la protesta social el año en
noviembre de 2019
mi misión
letal el 13 de noviembre de 2019 se lo
agradecieron
el 15 de noviembre de 2019
dos días después se producía la masacre
destacaba en las llamadas masacres de
sacaba en cochabamba y se encarta en la
paz murió más de una veintena de civiles
en enfrentamientos con el ejército
boliviano cuando ya nine años ya había
asumido como presidenta interina para
respaldar sus denuncias el canciller
boliviano presentó una carta firmada por
el entonces comandante de la fuerza
aérea boliviana jorge gonzalo terceros
dirigida al entonces embajador argentino
en la paz
en ella el militar le agradece al
diplomático el envío de material bélico
de agentes químicos como cartuchos y
gases lacrimógenas
el actual presidente argentino alberto
fernández afirmó sentía dolor y
vergüenza en una misiva que remitió a su
homólogo boliviano luis arce se constató
que desde nuestro país se remitió una
partida de material que no puede ser
interpretada sino como un refuerzo a la
capacidad de acción de las fuerzas
sediciosas contra la población boliviana
en esos días se trató de una
colaboración decidida por el gobierno
del entonces presidente mauricio macri
con la represión militar y policial que
sufrieron quienes defendían el orden
institucional en su país
el ministro boliviano también señaló a
ecuador de haber asistido al gobierno
interino de agnès jorge gonzalo terceros
se encuentra actualmente en prisión
preventiva acusado de sedición